l'expression de la loi c'est la loi et
la police elle est là pour appliquer la
loi
elle ne décide pas si la loi est bonne
ou mauvaise elle n'est pas une
juridiction
elle n'est pas dans plus un pouvoir
moral et elle est aux ordres du
gouvernement le chef de la police en
france police central il centralise et
unitaire ce qui est différent de la
plupart des autres pays
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
essentiellement le ministre de la police
quand il ne se proclame pas premier
policier de france dont qui finalement
la police elle est là pour défendre
l'ordre et je précise d'ailleurs
particulièrement en france que la police
d'état elle a été inventée pour défendre
les institutions et pas les citoyens
la tradition de la police d'état en
france et la défense des institutions
ce sont les polices locales et
municipales qui défendent l étude des
citoyens jusqu'à leur étatisation par le
maréchal pétain et on n'a pas réussi à
revenir en arrière en 1946 lors du
premier référendum qui permettrait le
retour à la démocratie parce que le
parti communiste était tellement
puissant en france que la plupart des
grandes villes est athée gérer ou était
encerclé par des villes et des banlieues
et rouge et donc l'état a refusé à
reculer devant l'idée de confier à ces
mères là en plus des ftv des polices
municipales qui elle-même aurait été
armé et nous avons raté cet épisode de
re démocratisation de la police en ayant
une police d'état qui fait tout de
autant bas ce qui est rarissime dans la
plupart des autres pays ce sont les
territoires qui font la loi
la police est sous le contrôle d'élus
locaux avec des avantages et des
inconvénients mais il n'y a pas cette
centralité de l'état donc oui la police
d'état est au service de l'état
[Musique]